ION BEING RAIS
ITASY THE PAST Y
FE HAVE UNUEIN THEAY, NAT
EDIETY  AKIN TO THEBASEBALL IN
REND T TO ND ONEFR MT COMPAND D.
NEAT
SEE
TOBACCANIES WHO KEPT
CLAIMIBOUT SMOKING
EITHER.L MEDIA IS RY
UNDEINS
TOT.NSTANCES OF HOW AS A  AMERID
INSTEAD OF PASSIVELYAITINGSE R .
AN HEIGHT JOME PCH THE
SI
ALSO THE CHOTH GRETHE CODDLING
MINDCK.
CAUSATION ORORW
CAN YOU SOH IN ODE OTHER?
WELL, E
LATION DOESN'T CAUSATIOO FIRST D
THERE'S PLENTY OF THAT.
INCREDIBLY DED AND ANXIOUSCALLYR
LE AND MORE PORID 6 BASICALLY A
GI LAB AM IF YOU LOOK AT OF TIEN
FIND, TUALLY CAN
AT
>> IW T WORK OA
BOOK ON THIST.
TADING IT. OK PE
BACK IE SPRING WITIAL ATLANTIC .
AT.
BUIT WASONE WAY,
I THOUGHT OU HADDELABLAND MEDIAL
OF THIS  RIGHT.THAT IBOOK, THEIH
THATDI
NOABE
DEGRO WHIC AND
HATE EACH OTR,
AFFECTE POLARIZATION.
INSING IN THE LATEOIUP ANDENSHES
I DID MEIT I
IT SHOULD HAVE
T.
O EAARD FOR USE
ANYTHING BUT  LOT
AND FACEHAS DONE IT. IS ONHEXPEN
WHY CAN'T THEY KEEP IT
>>S HAUGENTH
TED ONISSUE.
WHAT CAN INSTEWAITING R WHAT'S
US SA?>> UH-HUH.HAS TO REAWE'REH
THIS IS NOT NO CONVERSATNOT
THE IN
TO LOOO HE
.
IT'S SICMEPEOPLE
WEE P
RET.
O GOITR SOME THINGS,ORELF, YOU
RAM.IC O
SO IT DOES HAVE
BUT WE NEED TO
ADV NOT COMIO DOT
TAKEAT
IT DOESN'T DO WHAT Y THINKALL IA
PLATFORMS.
>> CAN I JUST TAKE THE
VE UNPLEASANT,
PEOUNTER WE
E  BEEN MANY.
E THATO, PIA, THEY GET BEE
MAYBE, KNOW, GOING OLDOL W HAD I